leon brandt ist konzentriert es ist
heute ein ganz besonderer morgen denn am
freitag ist der schulweg anders da muss
er nicht hinten bei der mutter aufs
fahrrad sondern fährt mit seinem eigenen
der vierjährige benutzt wie dutzende
andere kinder den sogenannten bc bus
hier in barcelona eine organisierte
fahrradtour zur schule
die kinder lieben ist es gibt ihnen
unabhängigkeit und es ist mal etwas
anderes etwas neues
es ist wie eine party auf rädern
mit musik und applaus für die kleinen
sie haben die ganze straße für sich dort
wo sonst tausende autos fahren vor denen
sie angst haben das brauchen sie so
nicht jeden freitag für etwa eine stunde
ist dieser weg zur schule für autos
gesperrt so können die kinder gefahren
uns radeln der bücherbus ist ein projekt
initiiert von eltern die veränderungen
das ist die idee diese straße hier und
künftig auch andere straßen in der stadt
zu befrieden es ist zwar radwege aber
vor allem für die kleinen kinder ist es
noch schwierig in einer fahrradspur
geradeaus zu fahren darüber hinaus waren
auch viele rolle auf dem radweg und die
leute fahren oft sehr schnell das ist
für die kleinen menschen gefährlich
die kinder genießen ihr freitags
abenteuer
weil wir zusammen sind und wir mögen es
fahrrad zu fahren
es ist super dass wir jetzt ohne angst
auf der straße fahren können
breitere familienfreundliche fahrradwege
die vom verkehr getrennt sind kommen
also aber
auch wenn die pläne in die richtige
richtung gehen und die stadtverwaltung
daran arbeitet dauert es schon bis sich
etwas ändert
bis dahin rollt die party auf rädern
weiter mit immer mehr kindern die
freitags teilnehmen der bus kommt gut an
[Musik]